Another popular system file format is the extended format, commonly
used in Linux. Each file on the disk has a
data structure called an Inode associated with it. The Inode
is fixed length. It contains the metadata for the file, and
it serves as the glue linking the data blocks together
in the right order. It is this gluing function that
is the most interesting. The inode stores 15 data block
addresses or pointers. The first 12 of these point directly to
the first 12 data blocks of the file. This makes
the strategy efficient for small files. The thirteenth of these
addresses points to a block that consists of a table
of addresses for the next blocks in the file. This
vastly increases the number of blocks that we can use
in a file. The downside is that we've introduced a
layer of indirection. If this doesn't give the file enough
space, then we use this fourteenth pointer and not one but
two layers of indirection, giving us even more space.
And if this isn't enough, we have a fifteenth pointer,
which uses triple indirection for more space still. Juts
like in FAT, directories are treated as files. Only instead
of mapping a file name to the first file
block, they map a file name to its inode. That
path for accessing slash foo, slash file.txt, would look something
like this. We'd start at the inode for the root
directory and then following its data pointers
we find the data for the root directory.
There we find that foo maps to
another inode, following that address we consult that
inode and find that address for its data block. Looking in there, we find the
contents of slash foo. That's a directory. So
it's going to map the file name file.txt
to the appropriate inode. And then using that inode structure,
we're able to peace together the data that we need.